un permiso que eleva las tensiones entre
estocolmo y ankara Suecia decidió
aprobar que el político de ultraderecha
rasmos paluda conocido por ser
antiislamistas llevar a cabo una
manifestación considerada por Turquía
como un crimen de odio como consecuencia
ankara canceló la visita del ministro de
defensa sueco prevista para la próxima
semana
hemos estado siguiendo el proceso
relativo a esta visita como ustedes
saben hemos observado que no ha habido
ninguna reacción de la Administración
sueca en relación con esas acciones
repugnantes y mezquinas contra Turquía y
nuestro presidente llegados a este punto
la visita del ministro de defensa sueco
para Johnson a Turquía el 27 de enero
carece de sentido e importancia por eso
Hemos cancelado la visita
este sábado a través de su cuenta de
Twitter el ministro de defensa de Suecia
pal Johnson dijo que la decisión de no
ir a Turquía había sido concertada Ayer
me reuní con mi homólogo Turco hulucci a
Karen la base militar estadounidense de
Rammstein Alemania entonces decidimos
posponer la reunión prevista en ankara
para más tarde Suecia junto con la
vecina Finlandia necesita el
consentimiento de Turquía para entrar en
la otan el gobierno del presidente Turco
receta ahí verdoán se opone a su entrada
y exige que Suecia extradite a 130
personas kurdas que considera
terroristas para responder a esta
exigencia a los países firmaron un
acuerdo con ankara en el que se
comprometían a llevar a cabo las
extradiciones pero las protestas del
sábado parecen poner otro freno a la
entrada de Suecia en la organización del
Atlántico Norte